Sometimes people think that emotion,
uh,
and art are sort of side shows,
the human intelligence,
the real essence of intelligence.
It's thinking logically if that were
true computers already smarter than we
are and because so much better at
logical thinking that we are.
Uh,
it's actually things like being funny,
being sexy or expressing a loving
sentiment maybe in a poem or an a
musical piece.
That's the cutting edge of human
intelligence has to do with the
hierarchy of the NEOCORTEX and at the
low levels,
uh,
things may seem cold and mechanical
cause where our neocortex can recognize
very simple objects and make very simple
decisions at a high level.
It's dealing with concepts like the
beauty of a poem by Emily Dickinson or
the,
or the ability to create a poem like
that.
And we can come back to creativity.
I believe it's an exercise in,
in metaphors.
And the NEOCORTEX is a metaphor machine.
That's what it's good at.
That's why humans are creative.
But we have this very large hierarchy
where we have more and more abstract and
complex patterns.
You know,
Bill's on patterns below it.
And the difference between humans and
say other primates is,
so we have more of the Neocortex,
we have this big forehead,
we could fit it in the frontal cortex
and therefore have a higher number of
hierarchies of levels of the hierarchy.
And that was the enabling factor that
that permitted the evolution of language
and technology and art and science.
We're going to create synthetic
neocortex is based on the same
principles.
I'm actually working on that.
Uh,
and we've had hierarchical systems like
that.
I helped pioneer a concept called
hierarchical hidden Markov models
similar to what happens in the brain,
but we only had a few levels.
The brain has a very large number of
levels and all the way from recognizing
edges of objects up to,
you know,
she's beautiful or creating a beautiful
painting or work of music or scientific
insight.
Um,
we will create artificial neocortex,
it said,
have a comparable number or a greater
number.
And,
and I think the principal application
will actually be to extend our own
neocortex.
We have 300 million pattern recognizers
in the neocortex by my estimate.
That hierarchy we build ourselves.
Each of these pattern recognizers
capable of connecting itself to other
neocortex is to build this hierarchy.
We build that hierarchy from the moment
we're born or before that,
uh,
we're constantly building it,
but we run up against this limitation of
300 million.
We'll be able to extend that and
thinking the cloud,
you know,
if you do anything interesting with
this,
do a search or language or,
uh,
bring up a map or ask it a question.
It doesn't take place in the box.
It goes out to the cloud.
We're going to put these just really w,
uh,
gateways a gateway to the cloud.
We're going to put gateways to the cloud
in our brains and have more than 300
million.
Uh,
just like the cloud can give you a
thousand or a million computers for a
10th of a second,
you need another billion pattern.
Recognizers uh,
uh,
you'll be able to access that in the
cloud.
That's where we're headed.
And it will be more intelligent,
uh,
enabled to actually think in a greater
number of hierarchies.
If you think that realized that the
quantitative improvement from primates
to humans with a big forehead to allow
larger Neocortex,
uh,
was the enabling factor for language art
and music and science.
Uh,
what kind of qualitative leap can we
make with another quantitative increase?
And that's,
that's I think where we're headed.
Okay.